how do I make so many videos so quickly
I'm going to answer that question in
today's episode of ASCAP greetings from
New Orleans today i'm answering a
question for my youtube viewers love you
guys link allen who wrote in to say how
do you come up with so many ideas I make
multiple good videos so quickly PS great
job thanks for that Alan I appreciate it
and I'm going to share three things I
hope will help you that have helped me
one practice I practice I practice I
practice I practice you might look at
this channel and you might think it's
easy but it's not easy and if I made it
I made it seem like it's easy and I
apologize because it is not when I first
started I was doing you know one video a
week it would take me an entire day to
do a video that I wasn't even happy with
and through practice and practice and
practice and practice and practice I got
better and now you know I've recorded
almost 2500 videos not all of them are
live on my channel but 2500 videos man
that's a lot of videos you'd expect to
get better after practicing and
practicing in practices so if you want
to get better what you're doing then you
need to practice and just keep
practicing and getting better and better
and better number two is i only talk
about stuff that I know something about
a buncha guys ask me questions that it's
outside my domain right like I'm not the
expert in that field and so you know I
don't want to try to pose as an expert
in something that I don't actually know
about and so the more you're talking
about things that you've tried and
tested and you're good at the easier it
is to make the video if I had to go and
talk about I don't know chairs you know
I'm not the chair expert and I don't
want to go and do that research right I
wouldn't answer that question so I only
take questions I can actually answer and
three is get a team you know I got a
team of people who helped me out and do
all this with me it's not just me by
myself you know now I've got two and a
half people
helping me I've got a full-time video
editor I've got a second part time video
editor because it's a lot of work for
one person and I've got a full-time
researcher helping me out and then I
guess you know other people on my team
jump in and out as needed for the
business so maybe around three full-time
people plus me doing the YouTube channel
and don't let that stop you from
starting because yeah I have my team and
I'm able to now jump from one video a
day the two videos a day and now to
three videos a day and letting me focus
on what I'm good at what I enjoy doing
but you can start now just start you
know like anything that you want to make
a reality that you want to have happen
it's all about committing the time to
making it happen no you want to produce
great videos you could do one video a
day and put it on your channel do
everything yourself you got to be all in
on it it's got to be a priority you got
to make it important you have to chunk
out blocks of your day to say this is
what I'm going to be focusing on me as a
speaker making these videos again and
again and again and again until I get
better so that's how i do it i hope it
helps if you're doing your chairman i
want to see it put something amazing
that something that you're proud of and
speaks to me thank you for watching you
can you to believe guys and for those of
you who are making videos i'm curious as
to how much time you spend per week
making the video that's like thinking of
the script thinking to the research
recording and editing that publishing it
how much time you spend per week i'm
curious to find out leaving the comments
below thank you guys for watching I'll
see you soon